[Music]
we're all expecting mal to save the day
but what did she's not the hero of the
story this time around every villain has
their eye on mal so someone else might
sneak up and save Oregon trust us when
we say that the hero might just be the
person you least expect we've got our
eyes on you Jane
all hail Jane the underdog she's sweet
loyal and everything Carlos could ever
want in a girlfriend but what if she was
more than that
what if Jane turned out to be the hero
of the story in The Descendants three
official trailer we see Jane taking a
dip in the enchanted Lake
she submerges herself into the water
while fully clothed
indicating that she might very well be
up to something and since Jane is the
furthest thing from a villain we think
she may be on a quest of her own
but how could Jane possibly save auradon
from its looming threat that's what
we're determined to figure out let's
look at the facts when we first meet her
in descendants all Jane wants is to be
beautiful she gets a makeover courtesy
of mal and starts coming out of her
shell but by the end of the movie Jane's
lost her cool new hairdo and does
something totally unexpected
she snatches her mother's wand during
Ben's coronation and mistakenly blows a
hole in the Isles barrier Jane knew that
she would get in trouble but she didn't
care so we already know that she's brave
and reckless which are two common treats
every heroes got in the bag another
thing that comes in handy when you're a
hero in the making is magical abilities
or powers of some sort but Jane doesn't
have any powers or does she we need look
at who her mother is she's the one and
only fairy godmother you know the one
responsible for saving Cinderella and
reviving the villains and trapping them
on the Isle of the Lost
knowing this it would make perfect sense
for Jane to have powers of her own
with very magic on her side Jane could
find a way to save auradon although most
of us are preoccupied with Ben and mouse
story it would appear that Jane's on a
mission of her own why else would we see
so much of her in the d3 trailers in the
meet Celia trailer we see Celia reading
Jane's Tarot hero it's me a tall
handsome stranger to which Jane replies
I already have but since Carlos is
average height the opposite of a
stranger we're guessing genes mystery
encounter is going to play a hand in her
story
James Strange tarot reading isn't the
only time we see her though because she
pops up again in the official trailer
but this time Jane's escaping a cloud of
pink smoke and taking a dip in the
enchanted lake
she's wearing the same dress she was
wearing at her tarot reading so Jane's
actions are more than a little peculiar
what in auradon could Jane possibly be
up to it looks like Jane might be
escaping the sleep spell but upon
further inspection we realized something
a little weird
the pink smoke doesn't appear when dizzy
squeaky and squirmy fall asleep on the
couch but it does appear when fairy
godmother Ben and the VIII case turned a
stone so could Jane really be trying to
escape the stone spell and if so how
could she save the day without hades
amber well maybe locating Hades ember is
exactly what Jane is up to the one thing
more powerful than the curse of the
scepter is Hades ember so locating this
magical blue jewel is probably of the
utmost importance but doesn't Emma have
the Ember and didn't Celia destroy it
right before my very eyes well see
Leah's a master of illusions so maybe
she just wants everyone to believe that
the ember is gone forever here's what
we're thinking guys remember that Tall
Dark Stranger Celia was talking about
well what if he tells Jane to go to the
enchanted lake to retrieve the amber
just as the BK's turned to stone
once emerge Dean wouldn't fall victim to
the stone spell and she could retrieve
the Ember we know what you're thinking
how did the Ember get from the well to
the enchanted lake right well what if
they're connected the water must be
pretty magical for the ember to combust
like it did once fully submerged so
perhaps the
is a well that goes directly to the
enchanted lake since most people didn't
dive into a lake with all of their
clothes on Jane is probably looking for
something and since she opens her eyes
once she's under we're pretty sure she's
trying to find a blue and glowing Ember
but once she's got her hands on it
what's she going to do with it
that's for Disney to know and us to find
out
but whether Jane finds and uses the
amber to break the spell or gives it to
someone who can the fact remains the
same
Jane is a total hero with every single
one of her allies turned to stone it's
safe to say that mal is going to need a
little help saving Oregon and who better
to lend her a helping hand than Jane
herself after all both her mother and
her boyfriend have been turned to stone
so why wouldn't Jane do everything she
can to save auradon what do you guys
think does Jane have what it takes to be
a hero and will she be the hero in
descendants three let us know your
theories in the comments section below
for more videos about your favorite
Disney characters subscribe to the
things and be sure to give this video a
big thumbs up while you're at it thanks
for watching see ya
[Music]